[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum how is everyone today
ryan how are you i am a-ok how are you
are you i'm doing all right man i'm uh
i've been exercising more and i've
noticed my anxiety has gone down a
little bit funny how that happens isn't
it isn't it we just talk and preach and
[ __ ] and then once you actually do
it you see oh well i notice a little
difference even if it's a small
difference it's a freaking difference
man oh yeah you see these things at the
bottom of my legs if i move those around
a lot then yeah the things you put the
feet feet yeah if you sort of move those
up and down yep and around and outside
your heartbeat starts to go up it's
crazy it's amazing guys i hope you're
taking care of yourselves i hope you're
uh thanks for listening whether you're
in your car or you're at home or
whatever thanks for tuning in uh john
wesley ship coming up
great guest you know him from the flash
you know him from dawson's creek he
talks about his relationship with mark
hamill he talks about um i mean just
anxiety life
he was very uh
open and i love when the guests are open
you guys always write me and say god
they were so open and i love how you
know you're able to open guests up and
you
they just either want to or not and uh
he seemed to open up quite a bit and uh
it was effective it helped me
um if you're liking the podcast i urge
you to spread the word help the podcast
out um follow us on instagram twitter
and facebook instagram and facebook is
that inside you podcast and at inside of
you pod on the twitter
and it's right here you can see it see
that
and what else
you could watch on youtube but subscribe
write a review it helps the show out and
spread the word
um really my patrons are
the saviors of this podcast so if you
want to join patreon and help the
podcast in other ways keep it rocking go
to patreon.com inside i'll send you a
message right after inside of you oh
inside of you patreon.com inside of you
that's right is that right
patreon it's like a family you'll see it
it's there's like a lot of perks and
tiers and
things that you could do and to help the
podcast in other ways patreon.com inside
of you um
and if you want any merch banned merch
is at sunspin.com you could also zoom me
um i'm on cameo and uh also if you want
any merch from the inside of your store
like lex luthor stuff small box small of
a lunch boxes uh inside your store
online inside of you online store you
can go there um
anything else ryan going on in your life
uh
well i got back from
uh you were about to show a bachelor
party in san diego did you get drunk uh
yeah was it fun it was a lot of fun and
you didn't pass out or anything i didn't
pass out no uh there uh the the group
was uh
you know it was it was like an array of
this guy's friends from like high school
all the way to like professionals so it
was like it ran the gamut of of of dude
right uh so it was fun i'm glad you had
a good time yeah that's good because
last time you had a seizure i had a
seizure on a beach and i ruined a
bachelor party this time i didn't i was
not the one who ruined the bachelor
party that was somebody else well i'm
glad you're healthy and glad the uh but
actually it wasn't ruined it was we all
had a good time but right except you i
had no miserable time yeah you felt like
you ruined everything that's right but
uh i'm glad you had a good time this
weekend
it's good to get away isn't it it was so
weird to be around people and have
conversations and um
but yeah we were all we're all vast and
we all kept it within the group like we
had a house and we did a brewery tour on
a bus
and uh that sounds like food we went on
a boat too that was fun really yeah
i need to take dramamine when i get on a
boat just so i don't get little motion
sickness this was all right uh
just cruising around the san diego bay
for three hours sounds delightful well
san diego is beautiful yeah all right
well i'm glad you had fun man hey
everybody thanks for coming to lexington
comic-con i had a blast tom welling and
i had a blast who did smallville knights
it was hilarious and fun if you ever get
a chance to do smallville nights i'm
doing one in west virginia on september
24th i'll be there um rocking the
mountaineer comic con
and get your tickets gonna be a lot of
people there i'm doing a one-man show
for smallville nights it's gonna be a
lot of fun a lot of freaking laughs
let's get into this uh john wesley ship
uh this is a really fun interview i hope
you enjoy it i know i did let's get
inside of john wesley ship it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience hey good looking how are you
okay i guess
you guess where are you
i'm in new york you're in new york you
live in new york
yeah i live in new york
and uh hold on i've got like messages
coming in and it's blocking my audio
uh did you say where yeah
oh uh long island city
that's like uh we see if you can see the
reflection in the picture behind me
then so we got a view of this east side
skyline of manhattan wow from the
queensborough bridge all the way down to
i call it [ __ ] you tower it's
they call it freedom tower it looks like
a big
right down that they've replaced the
world trade towers with perfect
did you uh did you just get tired of la
was la something you were just like i
had enough of it
i started my career in new york i was at
indiana university actually on an opera
theater scholarship
opera
yeah baby i started taking piano at four
my first piano teacher taught me the a
alphabet so she could teach me how to
play the piano
and then i was an opera theater major
and i switched my major to theater
dropped out moved to new york in the
late 70s before you were born and then
uh
i was born in 72 thank you
oh you were oh yeah okay yeah
yeah i'm not that young
well to me you are well you look good so
who cares
you know
i've gone through various phases
you know of looking like someone
actually wrote me on social media once
and they said
you didn't age well
sad
why and i wrote back and i said
depending on when you caught me you're
absolutely right
because you know
i've had my scary periods
and one was when i did teen wolf but
that
teen wolf dad was such a freaking psycho
and i was in a very dark period but i
looked terrible but it worked right
but luckily i
clawed your way back
clawed my way back hey so you know we
have a segment we start out with guests
now we're just trying this kind of a
mental health check and it's just called
how you doing and it's just sort of like
at this moment in time with all the work
you're doing and everything and just
life in general just it's just kind of a
checking how you doing
you know i have to say and without sugar
coating it that you know i'm
on one hand kind of amazed that i'm
still alive you know
really and um
well i've gone through and nobody knows
nobody i mean it amazes me but evident
but i've gone through my dark periods
you know
uh in the mostly in the 2000s right
after i got off dawson's creek
but um
you know i mean a year of quarantine a
year of having
one play cancelled
uh in greenwich another play that we
were workshopping to bring broadway with
producers about henry fond and jimmy
stewart i had an a hallmark movie an
episode of a tv show and eight personal
appearances wiped off the board i'm not
whining because i have friends
who do
almost strictly theater and they were
wiped out i mean they're still
hurting really bad you know so
i was able to
go back to work february 2021 and do an
episode take my jay garrick
to uh star girl
wow
and then i just got back from six weeks
in
vancouver
doing the last two episodes of steven
season seven for flash you asked me how
i'm doing
and in typical fashion i'm telling you
what i'm doing how i'm doing is
i'm pretty damn grateful
that's the way to belong that's that's
what you got to be i'm learning i'm
learning gratitude the more i
no matter what at the end of the day
just before i close my eyes and it helps
me sleep that i just start to think
about what i'm grateful for it's just
weird how that works instead of getting
in these dark dreams or these thoughts i
just go you know wait hey stop stop what
are you grateful for and i start naming
things i put my grandma's face in my
head and then i go to bed and it's just
i sleep better
yeah i have a friend a good friend who's
an actor and you know how we are i i'm
this way
i would bet you are it's that
you know who's on a series and he'll
look at it
and he'll hate everything he did
and he'll be telling his wife
god i hate this i could didn't do this i
don't like it and then she'll stop him
he just told me this he'll she'll stop
him
and say
okay now tell me five things
that you like about yourself
and that that's she won't
let him
go to sleep on that
negativity
tearing himself down
do you get like that are you someone who
tears yourself down or or maybe that's
something that was in your past or you
are you really hard on yourself
i find that the longer i wait
between the time i did something and
when i watch it
if i when i watch it and i do you know i
can't stop but i'm almost invariably
i've learned to manage it
but i remember when i did nypd blue and
it was such a big departure from
anything i'd ever done first season of
nypd blue the two episodes is the drug
addicted cop
and uh
i know what i intended now it ended up
being incredibly received and incredibly
reviewed but when i saw it i was in l.a
and i got so upset i jumped in the car
and i drove to uh it was either idlewild
or lake arrowhead
and just stayed in a motel i was so
disappointed and freaked out that wasn't
what i intended
and i still do that like i'll watch
whether it's recently a hallmark movie
or an episode of the flash i'll watch it
and i'll hate the way i look i i didn't
accomplish if i wait i forget what i
intended
right and i can appreciate what i did
yeah yeah that's going to be that's got
to be really tough to to well you know
yeah i'm a i'm really hard on myself to
i'm like oh my gosh look at oh i like
and i started to i mean look you don't
ever let that go i don't care who you
are people say oh come on just you gotta
let it go you gotta
you know it's it's
my friends would give me [ __ ] about that
but i i try not to watch things right
away like you said give it some time and
then i actually can go back now i hadn't
seen an episode of smallville in years
and i saw an old episode that was like
on his hula i go oh my you know why the
hell not and i go
i used to think you look so terrible
bald and you look like [ __ ] and hate it
and now i'm like dude you actually like
her to be 10 years younger
to be 10 years younger watch it later
you have to go back
and watch your scenes with glover
and go
that is damn good tv
you have to you have to say
that is smoking i i can notice nuances
moments when i when i and that goes for
my whole acting career moments where you
go oh you really let go you were in that
moment you weren't thinking about
looking cool you weren't thinking about
saying it a certain way you were just
being and that's a rarity but when i see
that i kind of i i give a small applause
to to myself inside but that's rare i
don't do that a lot
could you imagine if i'm constantly if
i'm just sitting there watching myself
oh yeah you're terrific
you know it was very funny but we did
the the pilot for flash when they asked
me to come back is harry henry allen you
know uh barry's
father wrongly convicted of killing his
mother in front of a ten-year-old barry
you know which was not my origin story
in 1990 right brothers for cbs at all so
that was just a role i would want to do
whether i had never been
barry allen or not but having been barry
allen it brought those things
together you know it's like you talk
about being in the moment being close to
who you really are because
it was a unique situation i was playing
his father
i had done this
role
he knew i had played the role
i knew what he was taking on maybe what
some of his hopes and dreams and
insecurities might be
and so
there were times in those beautifully
written scenes
between henry and barry
uh in the in the uh
prison in iron heights that
you know i didn't know if
henry was talking to barry
or if old flash was talking to new flash
or if john was talking to grant
and when those things all come together
yeah it's it's really then but those
scenes i can watch and go they will
always be among my favorite
that's great that's a great feeling too
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico is just omnipresent they're
everywhere ryan and you know what what
they have some really great stuff going
on here and uh it's all about
convenience so you should listen up um
you know whether your rent or own your
own home it's it's usually
it's tough to pay the mortgage you got a
lot of bills um
but geico
is doing something just really terrific
they had created a bundling policy for
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy so you could
bundle it all together
have one easy payment i like that i need
it in my life it's simple it's cheap and
all you guys have to do for this
bundling policy so you could pay all of
this at once for low low rates is go to
geico.com you get a quote and you see
how much you could save it's geico easy
geico.com go to guycode.com today that's
geico.com inside of you is brought to
you by helix sleep um i don't know about
you but uh if i don't have a good
night's sleep i'm worthless i'm
completely worthless i have back issues
i have neck issues and i need a really
comfortable mattress and helix is just
the mattress for you especially telling
you from one guy who has a lot of back
issues and things and has sleeping
problems that you know your mattress is
the most important thing in the world
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete this is this is
really great it matches your body type
and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you
sleep everybody's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot or even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers
i took the helix sleep quiz
and i'm a medium i'm a medium i'm like
porridge i like the medium porridge not
too hard not too soft it's right there
in the middle and that's what i like
it's been awesome getting messages from
so many of you that have purchased a
helix sleep bed and i'm glad that you're
enjoying it so if you're looking for a
mattress just take this quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again isn't that
amazing ryan it's incredible it is helix
is awesome but you don't need to take my
word for it helix was awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
and by gq and wired magazine and here's
all you have to do go to sleep
now restfully just go to
helixsleep.com
inside helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside you take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life and you have
a 10 year warranty
so you could sleep you try it out for
100 nights ryan 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't like it that's pretty good that's
a great deal i think that's a pretty
great deal wow helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
inside that's helix sleep.com inside for
up to 200 off and two free pillows
helix sleep
inside of you
is brought to you by nitsa you know it
can be a little frustrating especially
if you're in a hurry or you're running
late to find yourself at a railway
crossing waiting for a train and if the
signals are going and the train's not
even there yet you may feel a bit
tempted to try and sneak across the
tracks while i'm telling you right now
don't do it
ever
to the naked eye trains often appear to
be further away and moving slower than
they are and they can't stop quickly
even if the engineer hits the emergency
brakes right away it can take a train
over a mile to stop over a mile to stop
by that time it's too late and the
result is a potentially deadly crash the
point is you can't know how quickly the
train will arrive the train can't stop
quickly even if it sees you it ends
in disaster
if the signals are on the train is on
its way and you just need to remember
one thing stop
trains can't
brought to you by nitza
do you do you look back and think
god you know if we had the producers or
the
just the knowledge we have now and you
know if we had different
producers or designers or whatever it is
for the flash of 1990 when you were
there
this could have been something big and
and also how did you deal with that
disappointment it only lasted a year
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah well we had it all
we were the most expensive show warner
brothers had ever done for television oh
wow at that point it was a high-tech
suit designed by
oscar winner you know bob short and
built
um
and our writing was great danny wilson
and paul dimeo were excellent i mean we
had uh howard chaikin
as a story editor we had uh i don't even
want to start naming because we had so
many
great and talented people and we were
nominated for an emmy for art direction
right when we did a big lot premiere on
the back lot for the international press
our reviews were through the roof i mean
washington post new york time i mean the
big louisville courier journal
you know and they talked about the
acting and they talked about the art
direction and they talked about at the
time
state of the art effects right for
television and so
we were a creative and industry
hit
now
it was the hardest thing i have ever
done i mean we would start at 7 00 a.m
monday morning and work till 10 or 11 at
night come in 10 11 at tuesday and uh
work till two in the afternoon on
wednesday come in at two and so by
wednesday or thursday we were shooting
all night
by saturday we were blacking in the back
lot at warner brothers to shoot day for
night and then we were back in at 7 a.m
monday morning um and you're in
everything you're in every day i mean
you're the flash
i mean our transportation department
whenever i thought i had it bad i'd look
at you know the fact that they were they
were having 25 26 hour days i mean our
overtime
was through the roof and we were already
budgeted
um so
by the time we did that through the
third week in august through the second
week in may with five days off for four
days off for christmas and that was it
wow because we had to do mostly live
action practical effects we didn't have
the cgi
capability
then that we have now and so it was
hours and hours and hours and danny and
paul were uncompromising
they wanted to do
the show that they wanted to see
and so
i can look at it today and i can
appreciate i can appreciate the fact
that the technology has come it's 30
years later one would hope
and i think what i was saying i think
what i meant to say was why didn't the
stars align for that project and now
that hearing you say all this you know
all you had all these great components
of it so why didn't succeed has to be
even more disappointing now you're like
you know it just was it was
revered it was all these things so what
was it
well as a combination of things i think
number one
it was 30 years ago putting on a
superhero
costume in 1990 was very different from
putting on a superhero costume in 2014
yeah the new cw show
we were like
i was hesitant to even audition for it
because i had been on broadway in new
york i had my two daytime emmys i had
you know i had fashioned myself a series
and i thought
only superhero reference i had
was being spoofed at that point and i
just didn't think that that was where
my talent lay and then april webster i'm
sure you know grip multiple emmy
award-winning castro director said john
just read the script
that's all i ask
and then i i read it and there were all
these human values there was the
unblessed son
of a cop family in which real cops
worked the streets but i had gone into
the crime lab so that my mom didn't have
to worry that all of her men
might not come home that night my older
brother was the street cop who my dad
loved and my dad was always putting me
down so bear my berry was the unblessed
son
you know in the family who gets these
superpowers and his first reaction is i
don't want to know from this i have no
uh desire to be a hero i have no
pretensions to be a hero i have settled
for my lot in life and that's the deal
until his brother's killed
and then it's like okay it's on and then
he has all this ability that he knows
his dad
it would make his dad so proud but he
can't tell him
so there was a i'm starting to feel it
you know by about that point right and
then they promised me we will not put
you in a pair of red tights
i came to kind of regret that later
because that suit was
so hot
it was i'd be in it for 20 minutes and
you could ring me out but i don't want
to you know the last thing people want
to hear is
those of us who've been fortunate enough
to play these
iconic characters yeah sit around and
whine about our students right right
right
but uh there were there were challenges
you know but i think it was it was a
couple things cbs had the oldest
demographic right
so all of our in-house advertising
did not reach our target audience number
two they were too confident given our
reviews from the preview that we did
during the summer so they're pouring
money into this they're pouring money
into this
and they threw us into their most
difficult time slot opposite cosby and
the simpsons at their peak
in 1990
and then
even so we held a decent third place and
cbs said if you could hold those numbers
in fact the reviews for uh the write-ups
in the paper was flash lifts cbs to
strong ratings week
even though we were third in our time
slide
um
but then we were off for baseball world
series for two weeks and then we were
back on and then we were off for the
gulf war
then they moved us to the half hour uh
an hour showing the half hour has never
worked in the history of television then
they moved our night
it was kind of good news bad news in may
when i had flown back to new york i last
seen with mark hamill five in the
morning we're trying to get the last
shot as the sun was coming up they
yelled cut i rip the wings off and throw
them in the air and swear i'll never get
into another superhero suit as long as i
live you know so it's kind of
the bad the bad news is
the flash isn't going a second season
the good news is
the flash isn't going a second season it
was just
i would be standing under the shower at
six
o'clock not knowing whether it was a.m
or p.m i mean it took us nine years
you're going crazy you're going crazy
going crazy going crazy isn't that
amazing how fast the body and the mind
can just deteriorate i mean you probably
didn't have any time to exercise really
you're trying to you know and you're
just physically mentally exhausted and
that's where you
you realize i can't do this anymore so
it's a blessing in disguise it like you
got good reviews you did this show uh
and it just it was killing you in a way
and you're like sort of relieved
yeah there was definitely an element of
relief although i realized
going into second season
i had already after the first several
episodes set some ground rules as far as
the first day of the shooting the series
i think i was in the suit for 12 hours
and then at two in the morning they
pulled me out of the suit for me to do
the barry allen scenes well i'm fried by
that point you know and then at times
they would go berry flashberry flash so
they would glue it on they take it off
with acetone they put on makeup to take
the makeup off they put the glue back on
you look like [ __ ] you had to look like
[ __ ] yeah
broke out in a rash
so we had to lay down some ground rules
do the berry scenes first
then do the flash scenes if you have to
yeah do the flash scenes and then the
beard but we don't go flashbury
flashbury flashbury
um wow and i would have been able to
make some more requests going into a
second season just to preserve myself i
had an awesome oh i always mentioned
dane farwell he was my stunt double and
he was as much the flash
as i was i was barry allen
but dame
was a rock you know
um
yeah so i i went to
back to new york and i did dancing at
luna on broadway but it won the tony's
best play i went in with the american
cast and howard stringer at corporate
cbs was at the tony awards and he came
up and introduced himself to me and
apologized
for how badly
they had mismet handled the show
wow
i mean when you look back i mean you've
done i mean you studied opera i still
can't believe it if i said la donna
mobile what would you say
i would say well first of all i think of
pavarotti because it's a tenor arya and
i can't remember
exactly what opera it's from
but it's uh it's a tenor arya and
pavarotti made it famous can you jump
into it can you jump into that voice
whenever you want is it something you
can just jump into
not so much now
i mean there are certain things that
happen
physiologically right you're not
practicing every day it's a muscle what
used to be a spin
is now
a wide wobble right i mean we all hear
that in it happens in every voice you
know
and so
you know whereas i used to sing
constantly and i would do recitals and
we'd do studio recitals and i keep it
for myself
but now i i don't it's it's becoming so
hard to even just practice for my own
satisfaction because it's
physiologically just gotten so difficult
yeah i i always
admire people who have done soap operas
because and you've won awards because to
me
it's something i could not do to me it
seems like the hardest thing in the
world you have to memorize 20 30 pages a
day and i don't i ca it terrifies me it
terrifies me the thought of doing that
and i know james franco
got on the soap and he wanted to do it
and he really
you know put everything into it but was
it did you find did you like doing soaps
or did were you uh it was an exhausting
thing to do
it wasn't exhausting of course i was 24.
you know it's like when i was on guiding
light 25
and uh
no it wasn't exhausting and
i listened to the people who had been on
a long time who had a method for dealing
with it you read the script you take all
of your scenes out you put them in
chronological order
then you look at the week's work and you
budget out okay i have to do this scene
you know these oh no no because you do
an episode a day and then you do four or
five episodes that week and the night
before you study your week's work if
you're lucky enough to have the scripts
that far in advance and then the night
before you work on the script for the
next day what was tough was for four
months while i was doing
dancing at luna eight times a week on
broadway i was playing
this crazy character on all my children
at the same time who was peeking out at
30 40 pages wait a minute as you're
doing broadway you're also doing the
soap at the same time
i would go to abc at seven in the
morning and i'd shoot all day except on
matinee days
i'd shoot until there'd be a car to take
me to do the matinee they'd take me back
to abc i'd shoot in the afternoon and
they'd take me back
to do the evening performance it was one
of and then i do the performance i go
home and i tweak all my lines and i'd
say well how about this how about it was
one of the most energetic energizing
times of my life and i ended up
hemorrhaging the vocal cord you know at
the end of that um
but it was very exciting that character
interestingly enough carter jones and
all my children served as the basis of a
thesis
at a major university on
my character was very violent very
misogynistic and abusive toward women
and how at the same time there was a
fascination with that character and
a repulsion you know and the
intersection of those two things um i
couldn't believe what we were doing on
daytime tv then we would never be
they'd never be able to do it now even
when i went back to play eddie ford in
2010 on one life to live
it was great fun but i mean i couldn't
even believe what we were saying
you know pansy ass boys you're a [ __ ]
of a mother you're all this on daytime
wow
you know yeah
that's crazy do you do you ever get
i mean do you ever get stressed in terms
of do you ever get anxiety or or with
work or
always trying to be great or proving
yourself do you think that sort of never
ends is that something you've dealt with
in your career or have you you know
never really dealt with things a lot of
anxiety no it's sometimes i wonder why
you always because it's
you move from anxiety i talk about
myself move from anxiety to anxiety
there's a period when you don't have a
part the anxiety is am i going to get an
audition then you get an audition the
anxiety am i going to do well and then
the anxiety of did i get the part you
have five minutes of in
i got the part
and then anxiety right now
because you only you're always
you know it's one reason i moved back to
new york you're always as good as your
next
project right well what are you doing
you know it's like
how about if i do this right now how
about if i talk to michael
be present be present damn it
yeah
yeah but uh yeah yeah it's uh
but there's but you know i remember in
those wonderful letters from martha
graham to agnes demille
where one of them says to the other
there's never any satisfaction
whatsoever at any time
there's only a sort of divine queer
dissatisfaction
that's so sad
yeah and a sense that there's a life
force moving through us that maybe
propels us
to what i'm paraphrasing now horribly at
a pace maybe faster than the others
right as an artist you know but yeah do
you enjoy relation do you enjoy
honestly being on the set of the the
flash
and and playing these characters and
working with grant and tom and all these
other people do you have an actual good
time is it a time in your life that
you're like i'm really enjoying this i'm
enjoying going to work i like the
character i'm playing i like what i'm
doing i like being on the show is is
that how you feel yeah ted is mostly
particularly
but then i was mostly just working with
grant and i knew
with him playing the son who was the
only one to believe that his father was
innocent and me being in prison it would
carve out a very special
relationship for us in the middle of an
action adventure
right at the amusement park you know the
lights go down the music hushes we walk
into the phone booth we pick up the
phones we can't do our business
we're sitting there all we can do is
memorize the words look at each other
make a connection and tell the truth you
know and those were
wonderful and i enjoyed it while i was
doing it i appreciated it pretty soon
after we did it grant was very funny
because i saw him at the upfronts in new
york and he had seen the pilot and i had
and he was like
man have you seen the pilot did you see
our scene you have a big scene with the
hand on the glass and the penny of the
father-son moment
and i said no
as it is how is it he said man i was
sitting there going you can't cry you
can't cry on your own scene it's so
uncomfortable to cry at your own seat
so grant wanted to cry after watching
did you did you when you watched it
did you did you cry when you watched it
i don't remember but i remember being
moved they did something really
interesting
uh
to get
me on the edge of my emotions david
nutter director andrew kreisberg jeff
johns greg berlanti we went in to do
that scene
in the prison and david came up to me
and said we've written some lines
that we didn't want you to see or hear
until for granted
until this moment
and it's my shot
so don't come in on your cue
don't come in until he says the words
whatever it was i love you dad
and i'm sitting there we'll see now i'm
really listening you know meisner would
have been so pleased i was
riveted you know
what's he gonna say
and he gets to the part where he says
you remember when you told me to change
my name because you didn't want anyone
to associate me with you well i'm glad i
didn't change my name i am proud of you
and i am proud to be your son
i lost it
so much so
that it was
unusable but
we said do it again right away don't cut
tape just do it again
and i was able to manage
the emotion and it was still there
people said how did you work up the
emotion for those father-son scenes i
said the problem wasn't
working up the emotion the problem was
not letting the emotion run away with
you so that you're up there having a
wonderful masturbatory experience and
the audience is going god
for me
true true because i think you know
somebody told me once if you're doing a
scene where you have to you know cry you
should think of not crying because most
people don't want to cry and they end up
crying so you're really trying not to
cry and that
is what really affects people i think i
think that sort of reaction what were
the lines yeah go ahead it's like
playing drunk
yeah you know people who are drunk are
trying not to look drunk yeah
yeah that's true
mostly most often unless you're really
obnoxious you know hey what were the
lines what were the lines they gave you
do you remember
which ones the one that i had not heard
yes
the ones that i said oh those that was
those were the ones he was telling me
we'll see that hit me on a number of
levels
because our show went one season
and i knew that they might want to cut
ties with the past
in order
to have a present and a future show that
hopefully would be as big a commercial
success as creative success which is
what i hoped for grant and uh
and when he lit into those words you
remember when you wanted me to change my
name because you didn't want anyone to
associate with me with you
well i am glad that i didn't change my
name i'm proud of you and i'm proud to
be your son then is grant talking to
john
is new flash talking to old flash right
or is barry talking to his dad it all
collided right
that's pretty amazing
inside of you is brought to you by keeps
these guys are wonderful especially you
know look ryan two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. oh boy more than 50
million men in the u.s suffer from male
pattern baldness and there are only two
fda approved medications that could
prevent hair loss keeps offers both
that's right keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home and you know how
much i don't like to leave my home
low-cost treatments start at just ten
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions discreet packaging and
proven results keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take up
to four to six months to see results so
act fast i have so many friends ryan who
are going bald they're like i don't know
should i shave or should i do this i'm
like why don't you try keeps first and
see how it works for you and then you
can decide it's simple
take a shot at something that works and
is fda approved
am i wrong here i agree thank you if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s keeps dot com slash
inside of you to get your first month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash inside of
you inside of you is brought to you by
better help boy this company has helped
so many people it's helped me it's
helped ryan here uh if you don't know
about better help just listen up if
you're dealing with any kind of
depression anxiety work overload you got
a lot on your mind you just need to get
it out um ryan we've talked about this
you're still doing better help still
doing better health still helping you
you seem like in better spirit i'm not
just saying that but you you can tell
better help helps you get better it
really does it really does and i like
these guys they've stuck with me because
i think it's working i think people are
listening and you know i noticed a lot
of my patrons you know they'll respond
like hey betterhelp's really cool thanks
thanks for introducing me to it and um
it's just one of those sponsors that's
it's not even a hard sell it's like you
know it's so easy to like do you want to
feel better about yourself do you want
to
fix things that you don't like about
yourself better help better help is
there if you're feeling depressed or
struggling with uncertainty or having
difficulty sleeping better help offers
experienced therapists who can listen
and they can help and you can start
communicating in 48 hours or less
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they'll make it
easy and free to change counselors if
needed you know if you have a did you
have to change a counselor i did but
that was only because he left the
service oh he left the service okay well
there you go i mean that's the thing you
meet somebody a lot of times you're like
huh i'm not comfortable with this person
right it's so easy you just change
they'll help you change immediately and
it and this is common this happens you
might meet the therapist of your of your
life
you know but you will you'll find the
right one uh it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available and that's
for damn sure um so many people have
been using betterhelp they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
don't even take my word for it just do
it take ryan's word for it if you want
because uh
we really believe in this in this place
better help online therapy and here's
all you have to do it's pretty easy
inside you is sponsored by better help
online therapy and our listeners get 10
percent off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
inside
that's betterhelp.com
inside get matched with a better help
therapist and get started
do you do when you look back did you
think that uh dawson's quick was going
to be a hit right right away from you
you did i do why is that i didn't do the
pilot presentation i was off in moab
utah for five weeks doing the lost
treasure of jos santos with david
carradine lee majors kathy lee cross wow
wow it's a movie that you will never see
i don't know i might now
they decided to go a different way with
the dad after the pilot presentation and
after it was picked up
um
don't feel bad for that actor because
the next thing i know i'm sitting in a
movie with al pacino and he's so i got
dawson speak he got the movie without
pacino okay so
i don't know well the tv show lasts
longer than the movie a movie is kind of
there and it's gone it's true but i they
had me watch it the pilot presentation
and i knew immediately
and we forget this
uh because it became such a pop cultural
phenomenon we forget
how unusual
it was at the beginning to have a show
in which the kids
were talking like that were dealing
emotionally and internally with issues
and trying to express them in a
vocabulary that very few kids had i
remember a big star said to kevin
williams son one time kids don't talk
like that and without hesitation he shot
back maybe not that they'd like to
so
it was wilmington north carolina the
creek was an actual character in the
show the waters
of that you know uh
southeastern coastal waterway town
and
the issues that they were dealing with i
mean people forget it was the critically
acclaimed dawson's creek the first
couple of seasons sure yeah oh yeah and
i knew immediately i thought
wow
this is special and then i talked to
kevin williamson and he said
i promise i won't turn you into
i'm going to say the name of the show
because that sounds disparaging a
certain kind of tv parent
he said you will have real
subsidiary but independent storylines
that intersect with and inform
what the kids are going through you
won't just be mom and dad in the kitchen
stand have a good day at school you know
and he was as good as his work you know
because there were
there were there were some really
intense
episodes
yeah i even watched it i remember
watching i couldn't help but watch it i
had to watch that show
and i mean i ended up working with josh
in a movie called urban legend but did
you did you get along with everybody i
mean obviously you worked with james a
little more right
yeah yeah yeah i worked with james the
most it was interesting to see these
young actors and i think we were we
benefited from being in north carolina
out of the glare of l.a you know because
these
uh young actors went from
relative unknowns to
i mean
superstardom
and their faces on the covers of all
these magazines
that fast right you know
and uh
to watch the way they handled it i mean
it was i mean i remember james when he
signed his first autograph had to go
tell mary margaret humes about it she
played his mom right right and when his
movie
varsity blues came out
his parents weren't in town so we asked
mayor margaret and i to go with him to
see it wow
so that is pretty damn cool so he asked
his tv parents to go with him to the
premiere for varsity blues
that's pretty sweet that's pretty damn
sweet now i bet his parents were upset
they're like we would have come
jeez well it wasn't it wasn't the
premiere but it was showing right in in
north carolina you know
yeah
it was it was very very sweet but it was
also interesting to watch
you work with josh you know josh has a
very different way of working
from james
who at that time was very cerebral
you
know very very emotionally logical
i mean uh i was watching this young man
of course he had worked with uh
uh oh god
edward albee
as a playwright on a play so i mean he's
he had he knew the work
and and he would have notes
after a script read through
and some people were offended by that
but
kevin williamson and i found this with
writers and producers who are really
secure
he was open to the notes he said yeah
but 98 of the time he's right
wow
you know yeah so um
but it was really interesting
and in the in the lives of those young
people to see how what they were playing
on screen was mirroring what was
happening off camera
you know what do you mean and uh what do
you mean
i've been saying more well they were
some of them were seeing each other
right
yeah
and they broke up and they got together
in different you know was that hard on
set
was it was there like some stuff that
went on
i have a feeling
that by
fourth fifth sixth season a combination
of things happened number one they were
getting all these
other offers right they wanted to make
the leap to what was next and whatever
character
conflicts personalities
different way of working accommodations
that they had to make
to work with each other
uh
began to really grind on
to irritate
them so
i was very happy to leave
in i think it was the fourth or fifth
episode of the fifth season you know
where my character died
eating an ice cream cone which was kind
of hilarious because i was known as the
ice cream man on set on devoured ice
creams any time right there
but uh were you upset when you died with
you did kevin call you and said hey this
is going to be it
kevin was gone
ah
kevin was gone he left after season two
and greg berlanti came in as for a while
and then
um
but i knew after season four
that there was going to be a shift
because the kids were going to go to
college
and they would leave the creek
and sure enough at the end of season
four they let all the adults contracts
lapse
and they asked us for six episodes
instead of 19
and i thought this has been such a rich
and wonderful experience you know i
i don't
i don't want to go back and be holding
the new baby lily and waving appearance
day
you know i just didn't want it to turn
into that right
and so i set my price
really high expecting that they wouldn't
meet it
and everybody went to start season five
and i was fine i was in la i had four
great seasons under my belt i felt ready
to move forward
and uh i think during the filming of the
first or second episode uh the wb shut
them down because they didn't have any
story
and uh and paul stupid called me in l.a
producer and said can i have coffee with
you and so i said sure
i figured something was up and he said
that here's the deal
and so we were wondering if you would
come back
we know you've been
a little bit unhappy the last season or
two with the diminishing role of the
parents were taken but if we
if we promise you two great scripts
and the money you're asking will you
come back okay i'm like yeah yeah and
killed the character
[Laughter]
it's like
but they were as good as their word
again those are two of my favorite
favorite episodes and they're
it was such a respectful
and affectionate
farewell to a character i couldn't
imagine
it really validated
it really made me feel that the previous
four years had been about something
special right you know and so
i felt that
it ended exactly the right way for
everybody it gave james propelled him to
therapy they made it so there was an
incident i won't go into it he was
responsible for what i went out to do
when i was killed in the car accident
you know on mary margaret had all of the
parental duties instead of splitting
them right
and she played those scenes so
wonderfully the the funeral and then i
had a six feet under episode where i
came back and i did visited visitations
with all the kids and sort of wrapped up
my relationships right and belonged
goodbye it was called
so yeah no it felt exactly right
do you think it's uh do you remember the
the first time you were told that you're
gonna play or you're gonna audition for
a parent or someone like because you go
from this transition of like i still
feel young i'm young i'm young and then
they're like oh you're gonna be the
parent of this in this audition oh i'm
going in for the dad now do you remember
that first dad role
no only reason i do
is because somebody else
my first dad
was in 1989
playing uh
uh uh barney bucks in never-ending story
to the father of sebastian
so i started playing dad's
nine years into my professional career
wow you know 30
89 i was born at 55
so i was 30 what four 34 35
um and i didn't think anything okay
until people were like
particularly dawson's are you going to
be okay playing the dad i'm like
why wouldn't i be
you know
is a good part yeah
and i played
superheroes and psychopaths ever since
yeah
where did do you keep in touch with
anybody from dawson's
mary margaret
appearances with mary margaret humes and
i did a pilot in chicago with katie
holmes yeah um
what was that 2018
um where she was an fbi agent but it it
didn't go we thought it was going to go
but so she didn't invite you to the uh
tom cruise wedding when they got married
no
you weren't married to that
you and tom could have jumped around on
the couch together it could have been
just
a real treat
no
by the way you went to indiana
university
and you went to high school in
louisville i grew up in indiana
and went to college at western kentucky
university and uh oh did you really see
yeah
we we fly we swap you went to smarter
schools though oh you know i love
western kentucky but i got i got
dunkey west the hilltoppers the
hilltoppers of western kentucky oh yeah
all right so this is called uh
[ __ ] talking
with john wesley's ship or i could
change it to ship talking that for this
particular episode
right
so these are questions these are
questions from my fellow patrons who um
love you
and they they get to ask questions so uh
here we go steph a
your personal favorite superhero or is
there someone else you like more
um
well i you know i have to hats off
tim burton's batman and the flash were
being developed at warner brothers at
the same time around a new
uh
aesthetic
for presenting these
superheroes dark
brooding we went darker with flash than
the flash really is in fact carmen
infantino who drew
the flash grouse at one point he said ah
they're making the flash so dark flash's
not supposed to be that dark
everything's all shot at night and all
the streets are wet you know but but we
felt we had to do that because we had to
ground it
in some grit
to have people take it seriously so i
would say
if i had another favorite it would be
batman
you know yeah
betsy d says are you excited to be
reprising the role of jay garrick
and i know i'm thrilled to see you again
on star girl
oh yeah i mean jay garrick is the role
you know when they asked me to come back
and get back in a new version of the
1990s suit for el swirls and then crisis
in 2018 i was like are you out of your
minds i'm like you know that was 28
years ago right but i think we pulled it
off but jay
is the character that i feel
is the appropriate part for me to play
now because
in the comics he's really in his 90s but
he was exposed to age-reversing
chemicals which lands him in his
mid-late 50s right so that's the
character that i enjoy exploring second
henry allen was still my favorite
ryan
i mean you're a big ryan's my engineer
he's here you have you seen most
episodes of the flash
uh
no
no you've seen a lot of them though i
have seen a lot yes
and uh do you want to ask john a
question come on you got to have
something for him he's like no
um
how is it
uh
how is grant gustin as a human being
good question
he was on this podcast i could tell you
but he's uh but you work with him
closely so how is that yeah i have to
say it was one of the
as i've already said it was one of the
most rewarding
experiences because
people always ask me what
what grant is like but grant works from
his truth so
what you see
uh there's there's a fun there's a spark
and there's an exquisite vulnerability
um
and a real dedication to trying whether
it's a superhero context or whether it's
one of his independent films whatever it
is to treat it
like we're trying to get to the truth
of something here
and let's work together and he does get
irritated
if
someone is not on that wavelength if
someone's not taking this seriously or
someone's not
on i mean you know because i i ran into
this when i went back to daytime in 2010
for four months i mean
people walking the halls going but
soap opera job and i'm like
that will kill that attitude will kill
anything you have to offer
any creative impulse you might have that
attitude will kill it yeah people say
what's your favorite role you've ever
done i said the one i'm doing right now
whatever it is
is my favorite and whether it's daytime
tv
when the audience had shrunk
considerably by 2010 we were having 22
million viewers a week in the early 80s
by 2010 it was like maybe 1 million
viewers an episode but whether it was
that or the tony award-winning play on
broadway or prime time or the drug
addicted cop on nypd blue are running
around at my age in a superhero whatever
it is it's that moment
that's my favorite
wow that's a great answer leanne p love
the episodes where mark hamill guest
starred
back on the flash uh any fun memories
you have about him that would you would
like to share because he's a character
well
mark was
really
helpful to me because i've already told
you i was very reticent to go into a
superhero suit so i was like i don't
have any lines in the suit
i don't want any b-roll in the suit i
don't want to have the cow back and have
like you know eating a hostess twinkie
and drinking a diet coke i don't want to
turn into a mascot right so i was pretty
stiff well here comes mark
as the trickster you know balls to the
wall oh yeah no whole i mean just total
100 commitment and i'm like
well if mark hamill
can commit to that degree then i need to
get over my bad self you know and i
think by the last episode of the show
the trial of the trickster when he's
mind controlling the flash
i was able you know i'm catching bullets
from the police and throwing bullets
back at the police which we could never
do today
um
and knocking over parking meters and you
know being his sidekick
i was actually able to relax and have
some fun but in the new show
he comes back is the trickster
in the news show and
we go to earth 3 and he's shooting
bullets at a bank robbery and i'm
catching them in my helmet
and i show him the bullets in my helmet
and i say you're out of bullets and he
opens his coat and he's wired with a
bomb and he says yeah but i'm not out of
bonds and our faces are this close and
they yell cut and he says
we're grown-ups
that's brilliant that's raj says is
there a moment in your career you can
point to as the time where you felt you
had achieved success in the industry now
this is a tough question because
you know that moment that's good enough
that you felt like i have made it and
whatever happens afterwards or the downs
the ups the downs but
you know i think about that sometimes
but uh how would you answer that
um
it's an it's a it's a process of it's it
it rolls out right
because i started in daytime
uh i remember when i won the first emmy
for
good guy going to psychopath douglas
cummings opposite julianne moore was my
leading lady
um
i remember jane elliott do you know jane
jane elliott actress she
she had said to me
because she had an emmy on general
hospital she said well you have your
emmy now you have nothing left to prove
i was like boy i can't wrap my head
around that i had constantly
things to prove and then i got a prime
time show that i was at the center of
and that was
a lot to prove you know and then there
was a completely 180 degree opposite
character on every nypd blue a lot to
prove and then theater every step of the
way and then
once you've established yourself i was
going to say made it but you never make
it
then you have to prove
if you're still interesting and relevant
in other words am i going to show up
on the set of the flash and the flash 90
costume and everything's gonna go
when's lunch
you know now as it turned out everyone
was so invested
in the comics that grant was like this
is the coolest thing we've ever done you
know and
and uh and uh the the executive
producers were i mean they really uh
enjoyed it but no you never i never
you never feel
what about you
i think you know when i hear that
question
it's it's weird how my where my mind
goes i think
hey
you had a lot of success
he had fun
you made some money you made people
happy
if i if i died right now i'd be like hey
i had success that was i mean what level
of success there's millions of levels i
mean i could say i'm not going to be
successful until i win an oscar or i'm
not going to be successful because then
you're going to be chasing even past
that oscar it's just not it's not it's
not tangible you have to find something
inside of you that really
you know you have to be proud of
yourself you have to you know i'm
learning to be proud of myself learning
to love yourself and i think that that's
how you kind of figure it out you go
what is success well
i've had success look at what you've
done
instead of trying to chase something
that you think is going to give you you
know happiness
so it's a tough question for me that's
where my mind goes
so i think that's healthy it's something
that i
as i've gotten older have had to
practice
you know i've had to practice
remembering
that over the course of a 40-year career
i've gotten to do things
that have been really incredible and
i've worked with wonderful people that
i've contributed
honestly and sincerely
to the best of my ability at the time
and in whatever project i love the
halfway through david copperfield by
charles dickens he does a reassessment
of his life and one of his great
achievements he says
is never to have put one hand onto
something
onto which i could throw my entire self
and that sort of has been ever since i
read that that's been my mantra wow
enthusiasm isn't that incredible yeah
say that again
never
to put one hand
to something
on something on to which i could throw
my entire self isn't that something
that and this ties into what i said
about soaps never to effect a
depreciation of any work that i was
given to do
whatever it was
have been the hallmarks of my life
something like that but those two
statements
that's awesome
that is awesome big stevie w last
question what's the one thing you have
yet to accomplish but it's high on the
bucket list for you
is there anything that you're like you
know
i'd like to do that you know i think
this goes back to
managing expectations you know i mean
things seem to appear
when i'm ready to do them you know what
i mean
whether it's the powder burns the
wonderful project david gregory uh did
where we won
uh an award the service award for uh
radio drama where i'm all rizzo sheriff
and ed asner was on it
or there's a wonderful play that david
has written about the lifelong
friendship of
henry fonda and jimmy stewart
despite vast political differences which
i didn't realize or know about the
extent of and romantic rivalries and
it's called hank and jim build a plane
because every sunday they get together
and they build model airplanes whether
they were speaking
whether they were fighting over politics
whether jimmy was talking
potentially to the house on american
activities or jane
was going to hanoi
whatever it was
and it becomes a metaphor for how do we
cobble together and stay in relationship
with people with whom we have vast
ideological
differences so
if ever there was a valuable message
for today and that was the play that we
workshopped in new orleans right we have
a jack batman and and and and bruce uh
at sunny spot
um
uh
uh shepherding that project well they're
multiple tony award-winning producers
broadway producers so and that was
interrupted for
because of covet but we hope to get that
back on track this coming winter
so
other than
wanting to continue to play a variety of
interesting
people
i don't necessarily care where it is you
know one of the most rewarding recent
experiences i've had was doing 12 angry
men
at uh at the judson theater playhouse in
pinehurst north carolina
you know
working with the best juror number three
i will ever see
and the two of us going up against each
other you know wow and uh doing it for
there was like a more house
scholarship thing five high schools
where they bought them to play
and they studied it according to the
constitution and what of the bill of
rights issue was being brought up all
through twelve angry men interesting now
that i'm playing henry fonda in hank and
jim
but
and they were right there with us they
didn't miss a beat that's amazing and at
the end you know that is as rewarding to
me as any high-profile project i've ever
done yeah isn't that something
so as long as there are
interesting parts and i don't drive
myself too crazy
but it's it's you said it you said it
and it's a practice i have to practice
reminding myself
that they're that i have contributed
yeah in meaningful ways
in a variety of on a variety of
platforms yeah and
am i an aid listener absolutely not oh
yeah i'm still believe me i'm working on
this
i think you would
without a doubt have and i think it's
also you have to practice
that
for me i'm trying to practice just
enjoy
this you said in the very beginning of
the podcast he said i'm here with you
i'm just enjoying this moment with you
if i could learn how to do that more
where i'm just with my dog or i'm just
with my friends or now it's work or now
i'm if i could just enjoy instead of
going through the motions or going
through these moments trying to get to
the next moment i'm i'm missing
everything
so i that's what i'm i'm working on
believe me it's a work in [ __ ]
progress brother absolutely so but look
this has been a real treat i'm glad you
don't do a lot of podcasts huh
no no not many i have done some but you
know this is great it's like i tell
people like conventions
my q and a's i'm like
if you've been to a couple of my q and
a's before i apologize there are only so
many answers before i start making [ __ ]
so
that's amazing i love it well this was
great i i really got to we kind of went
over a lot of things and uh i feel like
it's been great it's been great i feel
like i got to know you in this hour and
i really i really appreciate this and i
can't wait to to give you a hug at a con
because i am vaxxed now are you vac
fantastic me too we're gonna hug it out
and if you're doing a play if you're
doing something
if i'm near you just gotta let me know
when you're doing it if i'm close i
wanna come see you perform i'd love to
see you as henry fonda
excellent would be awesome i'll let you
know absolutely well give grant my love
and everybody on the flash and uh all my
best to you i appreciate you thank you
thanks michael all right john
bye bye
[Music]
um thanks for listening to the podcast
today um i really enjoyed his interview
i thought he was very open i was
surprised he was nice it was really cool
to hear about his uh his journey his
adventure with mark hamill and just his
his journey and how he gets in his head
and uh again i like when when guests
open up
uh thank you make sure you uh follow us
if you like the show at insightypodcast
on the uh facebook and instagram
insideipod on the twitter if you want to
join the lovely patreon to help the
podcast even more i'd be delighted i'll
send you a message right after it's
patreon.com inside of you
and um a lot of great guests coming up a
lot of great guests coming up i've been
working hard to get you good guests
and uh i do the best i can [ __ ] ryan i
just do the best i can i i get guests
that you know i can get
or i have to work at but i still get and
you know people seem to be pretty happy
they always have their requests and
you know they email over at hello at
insideyoupodcast.com
and they leave messages which i check
here and there
uh not that often but i get your
messages and sometimes i can write back
sometimes i don't but don't don't think
i haven't read your stuff and i
appreciate you listening and
and taking your time to write me and
sometimes they're really long emails so
if i just say hey thanks so much for
this i read it i just didn't write
another novel back to you so i thank you
um
yes why don't we get into the top tier
patrons these are the people who really
uh helped the podcast in the uh i hope
the podcast a great deal they they
really do and uh i don't know if i could
do this without them thank you to
cumulus thank you for ryan for being my
mad man over here thanks for jason
jason's uh taking over editing for you
because you've been busy as hell jason
has taken over the editing and uh he's
doing a great job and you're right and i
thank him for doing that jason we love
you man thank you so much for doing this
and uh keep up the great work everybody
give jason a shout out and bryce bryce
who really does a lot of uh social media
and tries to get the podcast out there
it's a great team and i'm happy to be a
part of it let's do the uh top patrons
here we go
nancy d leah
[ __ ]
s trish uh f
sarah v little lisa you kiko jill e
brian
mama lauren g nico p jerry
uh w robert
uh
b i
it's l i it's i think it's an l oh no
it's an i is it an i yeah is it it's
just a long skinny one
yeah
i think that's an i it is yeah it is an
i you're right jason uh w apathy and
kristen k amelia oh allison l raj joshua
d emily s cj p samantha m jennifer n
stacy l jen asked jamal f janelle b
carrie b tabatha 272 not to be confused
with tabitha 273 kimberly e mike eldon
soprano 99 more ramirez santiago m sarah
f chad w leanne p janine
uh r yes maya p maddie s
shannon d belinda and kevin v james
uh vanderbeek
r r
van der beek chris h dave h sheila g
brad d ray h tap the t liliana a
michelle
k yes michael asks talia m it's it's
harder when i go randomly like this
betsy d
claire m laura l chat l rochelle
that rhyme chat l rochelle nathan e
marion megkay janelle p trav l wow dan n
lorraine g carrie
b h veronica k big stevie w kendall t
angel m
rhiannon
c yes corey k super sam coleman g dev
nixon michelle a lizzelle lizai
lizai lizzai lazai lazai
jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c elliott m john b
brandy d
uh what yvore yvore camille s bond
jovi bono obama urbano mono the chief
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
um i thank you guys all from the bottom
of my hearts
and if i ever send you a box
for the top tier patrons and you don't
get it it gets sent back to me and then
i have to figure out the right address
because something happened and you know
what sucks is usually i have to pay
again to ship this box and if it's
overseas
but sometimes the address is not right
or it gets like messed around for two
months and then it gets sent back
first world problems man first world
problems hey i thank you for listening
to the podcast i thank you for allowing
me to get inside you guys each and every
day uh you guys mean a lot to me and i
like doing this thing so hopefully we'll
keep it going and i appreciate all the
feedback and all the love that you guys
share
constantly with me and uh ryan yeah love
you buddy love you too from michael
rosenbaum from ryan tears here in the
hollywood hills hollywood hills of
california california what's up guys
thanks so much for being here thanks for
allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you and uh until next week
let's uh let's be healthy let's rock it
out and uh
bring some friends along to listen to
the podcast will you all right thanks
[Music]